on se calme madonna madonna ivre madonna
pète les plombs sur à la g samedi
dernier madonna petite vidéo très
étrange sur instagram pour promouvoir le
remix de son titre frozen mêmes on la
voit boire du vin blanc tenir un
discours qui n'a pas de sens regardez
bien le demande de la cocaïne et tout
s'est passé sinon regardez ces voix-là
l'insta qu'elle a fait et puis on
discute en l'air
[Musique]
j'ai qu'une scène question opposé à
madonna stop ou encore de mort en fait
c'est soit pas encore c'est finement
manigances et ça se voit l effet madonna
c'est une rock star ça fait des années
que son fonds de commerce sexe alcool
drogue c'est ce qui fait d'elle aussi un
peu une icône de la pop donc moi
finalement cette vidéo là elle me choque
pas du tout c'est la continuité de
dizaines d'années de carrière qui kiwi
surf finalement sur ce fonds de commerce
donc quoi de plus normal que de voir m'a
donné amateurs des albums d'amy sont à
tout le monde sur l'écologie elle
donne des censures l'ukraine
à tout le monde hugo données de son sur
l'ukraine sur le collégien à tout le
monde et tout d'un coup il est môme qui
l'a regardé secret de la cocaïne bourg
et vous la gueule c'est pas un peu
chelou mais ça fait des années qu'elle
fait ça oui mais ce que parce que quand
on est dans des séries tu vois des gens
prendre de la drogue boire de l'alcool
tu le regardes la série tu dis pas tiens
ils le font je vais le faire c'est une
série world series série écoulé elle
passait pas notre mère elle en train de
nous dire le message qui parle je ne dis
rien jusqu'à cognac elle dit pas de
pizza regarde alors pardonne moi mais la
distance entre le monstre sacré le
monstre tout court elle est lé relais
local technique ouais mais moi jacques
une physique parce qu'honnêtement quand
tu te dénature comme ça ce que les
canards américain communiqué ils sont
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
forts
[Rires]
les informations qui est venu croire
que tous les cas mars france et people
prenez leurs infos parce qu'ils étaient
les prenez où nous aurait pas de procès
il les prenait où les prix maintenant la
donne a changé à noyau
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que dit
isabelle parce que c'est vrai que nous
les canards people souvent on parle des
américains ne font pas de procès nous
attaquent pas et il faisait par le
fondement il commence s'y met un petit
peu plus mais c'est vrai la ligue i met
you go entièrement hugo entièrement
responsable de network et vous êtes
complètement naïf c'est une star c'est
ça c'est un coup marketing ça a été
monté sa société passé trappe ils l'ont
retourné et cetera une star on n'est pas
une star n'en faire ses courses enfants
pris en allant rejoindre semblait
chercher ces projets ni avec dernière
c'est la même chose c'est bien sûr bien
sûr facile à mettre et la capap une
partie des coiffeurs tapis le canard
américain justement de la ceni
[Rires]
attaque et que si c'est faux dans ces
cas là et là les photos de madonna
impitoyable généralement le soleil au
zénith farid écrabouille bien la peau
avec leurs élèves y ont des horaires
différents mais la fin du physique au
monde il voit les ravages d'un exception
et criminalisation sur le sujet moi
quelques de ce massacre physiquement ça
me dérange pas mais qui me dérange c'est
le côté c'est le côté je donne des sons
l'ukraine l'écologie donc je donne des
jolie leçon aux enfants et derrière je
fais un scoop mais bon la gueule je
prend de la cocaïne pardon voilà mes
achats logistique c'est pas bio un donc
un nouveau tube loca dessus tandis que
l'ebit bon c'est pas le sujet du truc
vraiment de belles contradictions y
compris mon comportement dans une vision
logis et autres avec les idées qu'elle
prône coquet si tu veux alors bon alors
ludivine alors oui madonna a toujours
été très chic totalement d'accord hugo
j'ai toujours été extrêmement fans de
madonna quand elle commence une vidéo en
disant je suis la mère de jésus d'accord
on sait que tu as l'habitude de toute
façon de voir et aussi la religion mais
à un moment donné tu as 63 ballet quoi
même si et fait se fera jusqu'au bout
adacore décousu dingo visiblement mais à
63 ans tu ne peux pas te permettre sur
cela marley temps compliqués convient
d'aller faire l'apologie de la cocaïne
sur instagram en sachant que tout et
n'importe qui c'est logique au caire
dis est ce qu'elle dit prenais de la
coke a
fait une allusion comme sa petite
allusion en dix ans a déjà
beaucoup moins quand j'étais gamin et
que j'étais une fan je ne sais pas de
deuil s'étaient pas hamilton l époque
mais de senna senna m'aurait dit boit de
la bière tous les jours ça rend
intelligent genre et bu de la bière mais
tous les jours ce qu'elle dit enfin
elle laisse entendre que c'est cool
ouais mais attendez c'est pas là combien
de people sont venus avec leur champagne
à nana mais les histoires dans une vidéo
attend laurent est ce que ça te choque
ou patois mais vous soyez jeune ou
[Rires]
moins jeune c'est tout le personnage
j'ai aimé quand j'étais jeune madonna et
ses bas mais aujourd'hui ça ressemble à
rien quoi donc le choc c'est l'image
qu'on voit en réalité mais sa taille est
dur parce que physiquement vide
n'oubliez pas que ça ce qui est dit ou
tout et tout et crac quoi
giguère tu as sûrement vu aller manger
le buffet campagnard au campanile télé
star et sélestat ils sont bourrés ici
ont droit drogue dans les excès la nuit
son goût béton et cheveux extra ceysens
tourné vers moi j'ai envie de poser une
question aux loges bonnes questions à
déborah florian je la pose est est-ce
qu'il faut pas savoir quitter la table
de l'amour et des services
et surtout que tu couches
webber
servez chaud qu'une jeune recrue
et surtout mathieu personne ne le dit
depuis ta là on parle de ce qu'elle ce
qu'elle montre là qui est assez assez
stupéfiant mais qu'elle le dire ça
remplace son talent parce que c'est
quand sa dernière chance sur la dernière
chanson de madonna camarades et les
esprits et xv e siècle cartonné comme
avant je suis sûre qu'elle recevra ce
débat là c'est pareil de frozen et tu as
raison c'est qu'elle montre le mauvais
parce qu'elle n'a plus rien dit avant
toi moi l'amour
et bajule te le dire malgré tout le
respect que j'ai pour lui j'aurai un
chien je serai sur un canapé rouge de
dimanche j'aimerais décembre il
s'appellerait super le dimanche
parce que michel drucker m net d
matthieu delormeau c'est déjà dans la
tête de delphine ernotte je peux vous
dire oui